on est le jeudi 17 février aujourd'hui
c'est un immense match qui se déroule au
gymnase un bond de versailles ginette
sainte-geneviève lycée affronte lycée
hoche dans un match exceptionnel
regardez
[Applaudissements]
quand même
je suis avec l'organisateur françois à
l'avant alors françois expliqué noah peu
le concept de cette soirée le concept
que vous l'entendez c'est un match
universitaire qui dépasse le monde
probable est incertain du monde du
basket c'est une fête c'est une fête
unique deux entités qui se prestigieuse
qui se connaissent qui se haïssent
pardonnez moi le terme et qui vont
s'affronter dans un match
un peu envié à la sauce versaillaise ya
beaucoup d'ambiance ans l'entente
derrière et il n'y a que les ultras on
va remplir on va remplir la salle
chavatte extraordinaire et qu'est ce que
c'est l'essence de cet événement c'est
vraiment l'effervescence c'est ça c'est
une partage le partage des différences
il me je partage cette différence tout
su ce que les diversités
rencontrer des mondes qui ne se
rencontreront peut-être jamais
[Musique]
je suis au coeur des supporters de
ginette alors à tristan ça se passe
comment ça on s'est entraînés depuis une
semaine là on travaille plus on n'a que
ça en tête c'est le match de l'année on
attend que ça c'est moche c'est la
concurrence est clairement
le match de rennes est carrément le
match de l'année on attend que ça depuis
deux semaines en regardant du coup toi
là ça va mal ça fait deux seuls autres
avaient pu on a tous une équipe derrière
ce soir le match si le match de l'année
toute l'équipe est prêt on est là m
alors vous êtes tous maquiller ou êtes
en tonus était obligatoire ce soir c'est
pour marquer le coup parce qu'en fait
c'est le match de l'année n'y a pas un
seul médian j'ai passé à travers tout le
monde et tu monde est prêt et qu'on
s'entraîne depuis deux semaines c'est le
match de l'année et tout se joue ce soir
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors faisait part on vient d'aller du
côté de ginette font beaucoup de bruit
ça se passe comment du côté du ch on a
un petit peu la pression on veut on veut
faire mieux qu'eux mais moi je crois au
lycée hoche on est allés chez ginette
ils sont excellents mais que sa part
koch a une très bonne mentalité on veut
faire le veut donner maire de votre
équipe voilà voilà regardez là il ya
tous les supporters pouvaient voir il ya
une foule énorme je m'attendais même moi
je m'attendais pas à ça c'est incroyable
et vous attendez combien de personnes là
du côté un dos
à peu près 400 au total on a vendu 400
places en plus elle est professeur à peu
près il ya 400 supporters pour lycée
hoche c'est un peu la guerre là entre
les supporters ça se passe comment en
fait j nateur
rivalité qui dure depuis des siècles on
va dire si nos meilleurs ennemis on a un
grand respect pour eux on agresse le
bruit ils ont d'excellents résultats
mais on veut leur montrer que sur le
terrain et dans les tribunes on est
meilleurs qu'eux maintenant place à
l'entrée des joueurs sur le terrain
[Applaudissements]
avant de combattre dans l'arène du
gymnase mont boron les étudiant es
joueurs profitent d'un dernier moment de
communion en musique
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
non
une fois la musique terminée place au
jeu dans une ambiance bouillante
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
l'événement attiré de grands noms dj
l'as aux platines le dj des derniers
jeux olympiques de tokyo
huit mois marco freestyle champion de
france de la discipline mais également
fred avec une paye son ancien joueur de
l'équipe de france de basket s'est très
bien il est serré en bus intéressant
mais c'est tout ce qui se passe au toqué
décorum qui est intéressant c'est pas la
première fois vous voulez aussi un choc
c'est la deuxième fois deux fois mais je
revenais à chaque fois ça peut être pour
autant pas forcément joindre à chaque
fois qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans ce
type de temps l'ambiance folle ambiance
école il ya des événements entre les
cartons à au temps mort et cetera le jeu
est important mais ce n'est pas plus
important on nous a dit que c'était peut
être unique en france c'est ce que vous
avez ce sentiment là vraiment pour moi
c'est unis comprend quand je n'ai jamais
vu je voudrais me déplace à chaque fois
je me déplacerai bas si c'était un truc
qu'on verrait on doit partout pardon
mais c'est extraordinaire j'adore et le
niveau des commandes est bien meilleure
qu'il ya deux ans il ya deux ans j'ai
trouvé ça un peu faiblard là c'est
beaucoup mieux aujourd'hui au basket et
c'est beaucoup plus intéressant du qui
devait à la pause ginette et devant 29
avr
encore beaucoup devant tant qu'on gagne
la force
l'ancien maire jean yves jamait bini
jusqu'au bout nous a fait gagner on va
gagner en coûtera gueule
[Applaudissements]
joyent ainsi gilles a dit neil simon
petit mais ce match entre ginette et
auch c'est aussi l'occasion de découvrir
certains artistes et d'apprécier un lait
chaud à la mi temps
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
soutien c'est trop important pour nous
et c'était vraiment trop bien moche
revient dans le match et passe devant à
quelques minutes de là
[Applaudissements]
conserveront leur avance malgré la
pression de ginette score final 51 47
c'est officiel auch remporté son
deuxième clasico en 16es
[Applaudissements]
et où l'accord prime c'est magnifique ce
qui se passe ici c'est seulement la
deuxième fois que je crois pas ce derby
face à ginette et l'ambiance est
forcément extraordinaire pour lui
tellement couteau de cannes et au fond
l'année dernière on avait pu l'organiser
cette année en force à deux mois du
concours enfin une vraie dose de joie on
a éclaté chine et cela c'est merveilleux
tout libre et bâtiments sont en transe
hors tout de la 3d à roche et c'est
magnifique ce site magnifique shibuya
départ un peu de ma chauffe un souci
voilà c'est comme ça on sait qu'on est
meilleur mais bon c'est un risque et moi
on a gagné du point on peut leur laisser
fois c'est bon on est beau joueur voilà
bon après je supporte une ambiance on a
gagné légèrement c'est un beau match
quand même c'était un très beau match
relaciones grosse déception on y croyait
on y croyait à la fin mais bon il faut
accepter mais walker on est quand même
là dans lequel on a gagné dans le choeur
françois l'amant qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire après une soirée comme celle là
une magnifique fête
des moments de bonheur de rencontres
voilà du partage du partage vous avez
plus beaucoup de voix non j'ai pu le
voir parce que
pour l'entendre ouais j'ai la voix
brisée bougez pas comment vous étiez un
coach jean est ce soir pas trop déçu
quand même
oui un peu déçu mais le plus beau c'est
la fête soit magnifique est-ce que vous
allez sentiment que l'événement prend de
plus en plus d'ampleur d'année en année
où tout à fond
c'est via un engouement à un engouement
incroyable je mens 2 tout le monde veut
y être les joueurs la presse sauveur
dans toutes les directions et à 3,26
prof je sais pas tout vous dire mais en
vigueur rapide est ce qu'on peut
améliorer encore
on peut pas mettre plus de place
coûterait plus de stars qui étaient plus
de moyens humains
je sais pas aller ailleurs mais je tiens
à rester à versailles parce que beaucoup
de beaucoup de clubs nous propose ici là
pardon ce match mais on est quand même
très fidèle à versailles un animaux
peut-être
vivre au partage vive les excellences de
la diversité merci françois l'avant
merci beaucoup merci tu es 2 78
[Applaudissements]
à shopper donc 51 47 passes à ginette un
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour de
nouvelles aventures
[Applaudissements]